et Renault attendez mes mains ne sont
pas activées aidez-moi s'il vous plaît
levez-vous main alors ça roule je vous
parle aujourd'hui d'une nouvelle avatar
de Renault qui vient d'être révéler
directement sur le Mondial de
l'Automobile alors je vous explique moi
c'est Renault je suis enchanté de vous
rencontrer le principe c'est quoi c'est
Renault alors Renault Palmas Renaud
l'avatar c'est un avatar intelligent qui
va vous aider qui va vous assister ça
arrivera pas tout de suite probablement
à partir de 2024 sais-tu que je suis
doté d'une reconnaissance vocale tu
pourras m'activer quand tu voudras à
bord de ta future voiture tout ce qui va
concerner l'intérieur de votre véhicule
il va venir vous assister mais et ça ne
s'arrête pas là il y a une application
qui va arriver fin 2022 je serai aussi
en dehors grâce à mon application
Renault disponible très prochainement
cette application elle va vous servir à
apprendre plein de choses sur nouvelle
R5 sur la nouvelle R4 dans l'application
vous aurez des infos exclusives sur
l'intérieur sur l'extérieur du véhicule
mais également sur toutes les
technologies embarquées donc on voit
qu'en fait Renault n'est pas uniquement
Unia embarqué dans votre véhicule mais
c'est bien plus que ça et probablement à
terme pour la retrouver dans tous les
véhicules électriques de la